- I can't watch myself on screen.
Then why the fuck should we
pay 12.50 to watch your ass
if you're not going to?
All the getting high,
the drinking, the drugs,
and everything else I did,
I showed up at the theater every day.
And then when you go to soap auditions
and that doesn't happen,
you say to yourself,
what I really need is one
good national beer commercial.
(host laughs)
That's what I need.
- He's a prolific actor and film producer
whose appeared in over 100 movies.
He achieved prominence in the early 1990s
with films like Patriot
Games, Jurassic Park,
and Pulp Fiction.
He's ranked as the second
highest box office star
of all time, with box office earnings
of almost five billion dollars.
He's Samuel L. Jackson, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always, if Samuel says something
that really means something to you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(newsroom music)
- Listen, there's so
much shit you don't know
about what will happen to
you if you become an actor
or you become famous, that
all this shit is gravy.
That's what it is.
- But you're still doing the work.
- Yeah, it's about the work.
It's not about all the other shit.
The other shit is a byproduct of it.
Now you can buy into the other shit
and lose yourself in it, and lose yourself
in the bullshit people
tell you about yourself
and about the kind of shit you do.
Everything I do is not great.
Good, but it ain't great.
I do good work in some shit movies.
I know that.
That's happened.
I know what they are.
They know what they are.
But people watch them anyway
because there's something about them
that made me want to do it.
I enjoyed myself doing it.
It just didn't work out well.
But if you buy into all this shit,
or you start bullshitting
yourself about what all this is,
then you can get fucked up in it.
I read everything people write about me
because I'm that kind of guy.
I remember a lot of people
that say bad shit about me
because I'm that kind of guy.
I remember the people who
write good shit about me
because I'm that kind of guy.
We're in this business
because it's a look at me
fucking business, and if you say
you don't do that shit, you're a liar.
You're lying to yourself,
you're lying to the people who watch you.
Even those motherfuckers that go,
I can't watch myself on screen.
Well why the fuck should we
pay 12.50 to watch your ass
if you're not going to, ya know?
If you can't watch it, I damn
sure don't want to watch it.
I watch my movies.
I want to see myself.
When I was on stage,
I always wanted to see
the play I was in with me in it.
This is the perfect venue for that.
I watch my fucking movies.
Some of them I watch over and over again.
If I'm channel surfing
and nothing else is on
and I pass a movie I'm in, I'm in.
I'm there watching it.
Because that's what it is.
It's a look at me business.
And I got into it because I
enjoyed the fantasy of it.
I love make believe.
I love movies.
I love entertaining people.
That's what we do.
I kept going.
I had a path.
I knew what my path was.
My path was to become what I am right now.
Now I lost sight of it in
an interesting sort of way,
or I went about it in a wayward path,
but fortunately for me,
all the getting high,
the drinking, the drugs,
and everything else I did,
I showed up at the theater every day.
I did plays ripped out of my mind.
I rehearsed ripped out of my mind,
but every lesson that I learned
I held on to for some reason.
God, whatever, somebody,
let me hold on to everything
that I was learning.
My stage lefts, my stage rights,
my upstage foot always
out, turn down this way,
learning how to develop a character,
doing all those things,
because those are the things that I love.
I did them in the midst of everything else
that I was doing.
When my friends were getting
ready to get some more drugs,
I go oh, I got to be at the theater.
I'll catch you all when the
theater is over, when I'm done.
And I would jet.
Or I got to go build a
set, I got to do this,
so I did everything that I had to do.
I was focused on this
by any means necessary.
Plus I had a professor
who was like, you know,
well all the great ones do their jobs
and get ripped out of their minds.
You look at the Peter O'Tooles
and the duh duh duh ...
They get drunk, they get
high, they do what they do.
But they show up, and they do the job.
So we were like, okay,
and that's what we did.
(audience laughs)
We drank with him, and we went
to Styles of Acting class.
We'd go smoke a joint and come in
and do our other acting
classes or go build a set
or build some costumes
or hang some lights.
All the things that we had to do.
So I kept learning my
lesson and doing them.
- How often do you find
when you get on set
people are like, do the Samuel,
do the Sam Jackson thing,
do the Samuel L. Jackson
thing that we know and love.
- Not often.
I don't know what that is.
(host and audience laugh)
I mean, unless it's
saying (audio goes silent)
like eight times.
(audience laughs)
Well crafted (mumbles).
(audience applauds)
I don't really know
what that is, or to me,
the Sam Jackson thing
is I've read the script,
you know, I don't know how many times,
and I've broken my character
down the way I learned
to break a character down in the theater.
If there's source material
like for George Washington Williams,
I'll go to the source
material and deal with that,
but, if not, then okay,
it's up to me to figure out
who this guy is.
I can figure out when he was
born, who his parents were,
what his educational background
is, military if he has that,
what kind of life experiences he's had,
how he feels about this,
that, or the other,
even down sometimes to
what kind of food he eats,
you know, just because there
are eating scenes in the movie,
and I want to figure
out what I want to eat
when I'm in that particular scene.
And then from scene to scene,
what my relationship is
with those characters or
what I'm trying to accomplish
in this scene that leads to the next scene
that leads to the next scene
that leads to the next scene.
So what happens is, the
Sam Jackson thing, for me,
according to my agents and
managers, is I'm so prepared
when I show up that I
expect everybody else
to be as prepared as I am,
so when a director does not
have a shot list for that day,
or a director's floundering
and trying to figure out what he's doing,
he can ask me and I
can tell him, you know,
because one of the funny
things about movies
is the director's usually
the person on the film set
that's got the least amount of experience
of everybody there.
(audience laughs)
- The director makes one
movie every four years,
every two years--
- A good director's career is 15 movies.
Everybody here's done 15
movies in the last two years.
So we all know, why the
fuck is he shooting that?
That ain't going to be in the movie.
(audience laughs)
It's like, you don't
really need that shot.
You don't need that shot
(said as he coughs).
(audience laughs)
What did I digress from?
- No, that was amazing.
I don't care if you digressed.
- I show up prepared, so, to me,
that's the Sam Jackson thing.
When you hire me, you hired an actor
who going to show up, who
going to know his lines,
whose going to hit his
marks, and do his best
to make the other actors
around him better.
- [Host] Absolutely.
- I'm not going to call shots for you,
and I don't expect you to
give me a line reading.
And if you do, you hired
the wrong motherfucker.
Young actors have aspirations.
You look at movies and
you look at television,
and especially every year,
the Academy Awards show
comes around and you
sit there and you say,
God, I really would love to be there.
What do I have to do to get to that point?
You stand in the mirror,
you do your great acceptance speech,
all the things I would
say if I was up there,
who I would thank, and
as you keep working,
I often tell people this now,
that what happened to me
was I actually kept working
to the point where I
started to do better plays,
and different kinds of directors
that I came into contact
with and other actors
and interacting with
them, and the craft became
a lot more important, but there were times
when I stopped wanting to be a movie star,
and I said, well, okay, I
can, I can do a TV series.
Sure, I can do a sitcom.
And then when you
audition for a few sitcoms
and you don't get that
job, you say to yourself,
okay, I can do a soap, yeah,
I can sign a two-year contract
and do a soap for awhile,
and then when you go
to soap auditions and that doesn't happen,
you say to yourself, what I really need
is one good national beer commercial.
That's what I need.
A good national beer commercial.
I can get those checks coming every week,
and I can keep my theater habit going.
But when all this stuff doesn't happen
and you continue to work at your craft
and you do theater and you
work with August Wilsons
and the Lloyd Richards and
the Douglas Turner Wards
of the world and the Charles Fullers,
you develop a way of working,
and your craft becomes
just one of those great satisfying things
that you go to the theater every night,
you have a different audience.
People are sitting there, and you can feel
the sharing of energy
between you and them.
They're giving you something,
you're giving them something,
and at the end every night,
there is that great reward
(claps) the applause, and
you're very satisfied with that.
And once you let go of all of
those dreams and aspirations
and let your respect for what you do
become the most important thing,
the other things start to happen.
There was a point when I went to auditions
like everybody else, no
matter what the movie was,
because I wanted to be in the movies,
and I wanted to go to work.
And I had no choice.
Going to work was the option.
So generally I didn't see a script anyway.
They gave you eight pages of
sides with scenes in them,
and you might have got the script later.
After you got the job,
they give you the script,
and I used to flip through it
and see what page I died on.
And that was it.
But when you're out of
the audition process,
and you're sitting at home
and you're making choices,
then you should make choices
that are satisfying to you in some way,
and not monetarily.
They should be satisfying
to you artistically.
They should appeal to you as an actor
or as an audience member or as a person
who wants to make people excited
when they come to the
movies and see you do this.
It shouldn't be based on
all that other bullshit
about this is who they think I am,
so I've become this kind of actor,
and people appreciate me for this.
That's the one thing I used
to like about Jim Carey.
That everybody wanted
to go watch Jim Carey
laugh and be funny, but Jim
tried all this other shit.
Sometimes it worked, sometimes it didn't,
but he wasn't going to be
painted into that corner,
that I'm not just going to do comedies.
I don't have to be the three stooges.
I don't have to be W.C. Fields.
I don't have to be Chaplin.
I don't have to be a name.
I don't have to be John Wayne.
I can be all of these other things,
and I want to try to be them,
and he made an effort to be that.
When I came into this
business from the theater,
I didn't do the same kind
of play all the time.
I did all kinds of plays.
I did all kinds of characters,
and this is a bigger venue for doing that.
They have better makeup artists.
They have better scripts.
They put you in the environment.
You don't have to convince somebody.
You're in the environment,
it's there, they put you in it,
so why not do as many different things
as you're capable of doing,
and that was my thought.
I want to do as wide a
variety of genres of film
as I can, just to, you
know, continue to see
if I can stretch myself as an actor.
But then I was in the
Die Hard office one day,
and there's this sign on the wall
that I adhere to vehemently now that said,
be careful of the toes you step on today
for they could be connected to the ass
you'll have to kiss tomorrow.
(host and audience laugh)
And believe me, there have
been PAs and other people ...
Like when I'm on a movie
set, I think everybody
is just as important as I
am, or I treat them that way,
so I know PAs' names, I talk
to them, I speak to them
every day, I speak to the
gaffers, I speak to the grips,
I speak to all these
people, and over the years,
I've gotten jobs, and the
producer will show up and be like,
you don't remember me, but
I was a PA on so and so
and so and so, you were so nice
to me that when I was doing
this movie, I couldn't help but think
that you would be perfect,
and that shit works out,
or they become writers
or they become directors,
you know, but it's a collaborative effort.
We're almost the least
important element of any film.
Because if they ain't
putting the lights up right,
or the sound man mic is
jacked up, it don't mean shit
about what you're doing
because nobody can see you
or hear you, you know, so
they can fix that in the mix,
but everything else has got to work,
and you have to know that.
I dreamed about being an
actor for a very long time,
and why I was fooling myself
thinking I wanted to be
an oceanographer, I'll never know.
I always thought I wanted to
be the black Jacques Cousteau.
I just wanted to hang out in the water.
(audience laughs)
I always thought inner space
was always much more
exciting than outer space,
so I figured I'd go
under water and hang out,
because I like to dive
and do stuff like that.
But I've loved movies since I was a kid.
I spent a lot of my time in
the movies when I was a kid,
and I watched a lot of movies.
I still spend an inordinate amount
of my time watching movies.
I collect Asian films, so I watch a lot
of Chinese, Japanese, Thai, Korean ...
Koreans are making really
great films these days.
Indonesian films.
I just like Asian film.
It's more visual, and it
stimulates me in another way,
but I grew up watching movies
and imagining myself on screen
so aside from the very
serious things that I do,
I will occasionally do a
Snakes on a Plane because--
(audience applauds)
because those are the
kind of movies I liked
when I was a kid, and I
always wanted to see myself
in a movie with a bunch of snakes.
I'm still trying to find the
right slasher movie to do
because I like slasher
movies, and I'm still,
I did things like Deep Blue
Sea because I wanted to run
from something that had big
teeth and all that good stuff,
so I'm not that serious about it.
I really think movies should be fun,
and I think they should be entertaining.
If I want to teach you
something, I'll do a documentary.
But I do this because it feeds me.
It feeds my artistic sense.
A lot of people think
I do too many movies.
I read an article about
me in the paper yesterday
about me doing too many movies.
But, you know, writers get
up and write every day.
Painters get up and paint every day.
Actors only have so many
acting opportunities
in a life time; I'm going
to take mine as they come
and do as many movies as I
can before I'm up out of here.
- [Host] So on something like Avengers,
it seemed like you were
having a great time.
- I am.
- [Host] Not a huge acting
challenge for you, I imagine.
- It depends.
- [Host] But you seem to be having fun.
- Well, fun is important.
This should be a fun job.
It's make believe.
You and your friends wear
real costumes and better guns
and shit doing the thing,
you know, exciting people.
That's what that's about.
When you're doing something
like The Avengers,
you got to take it seriously
in terms of you believe
the space you're in.
You believe the world
and the convention of it.
That there are people who can do shit
greater than normal human beings can do.
Trust that, go with it,
treat them like they're
those kinds of people,
and they have an element of
danger and an element of awe
that comes with all that.
That's the honesty of the world.
But, you know, I'm fucking Nick Fury.
I got some shit with me
too, so I can be, you know,
boom, I can stand up to them
and say what I need to say,
and sometimes, like in The Avengers,
I need to manipulate these people.
I got to where I am because
I'm Nick Fucking Fury.
I can do some shit.
I got some shit with me.
Nobody knows how old I
am or why I'm still alive
or why I'm now black
when I used to be white,
so I got some shit with me too.
So you accept that and you go with it,
and you treat it like
it's something honest
and you treat it like it's something real,
so that when people come and see it,
they don't see you going (snort laughs)
you know, shit I'm in it.
I'm in it.
There's some dangerous shit happening,
and you motherfuckers
can help us fix that,
so let's go get them.
You and your friends doing
that shit when you were kids.
Let's go get'm, let's go get'm.
And then you shoot the motherfuckers
and they can't say you missed
because they chest blow up
and all that kind of shit
happens, and it's great.
Because I just happened
to do a British talk show,
and this guy asked me if
there were any directors
that I'd never worked with
that I wanted to work with,
and I realized George was
about to start Star Wars,
and I said I'd love to
work with George Lucas.
(audience applauds)
and somebody that worked for him told him
because they were doing
pre production in London.
I left there and I went to San Francisco,
and I was doing Sphere out
in the Napa Valley somewhere.
I got a call and they said
George wants to meet with you
if you're really serious
about being in Star Wars.
I was like, great.
So they sent a car out.
I went over to the ranch.
I met with him.
He was like, you know, I've
seen a couple things you're in,
but I don't really ...
I'm like well you don't
have to know, it's okay,
I just want to be in the movie.
And he's like, well, I don't know.
I'm like look, I'll be a storm
trooper (audience laughs).
I just want to run across the screen.
Nobody needs to know I'm in
this movie but me, you know.
(audience applauds)
I will run across the screen
with a white helmet on.
I would have been happy
because I just wanted to
be in a Star Wars movie.
- You were a Jedi knight though.
- Well, I had no idea, until they called.
I left there.
George says, well, you
know, I got a couple things.
I got some palace guard stuff.
Maybe we'll find something.
I was like okay great.
So I went off, and it was
like three months later.
I was done with Sphere,
and I was ready to do something else.
I got a call that said George wants you
to come to London, can
you come to London now?
I said, sure.
I get on a plane, I go to
London, I get to the studio,
they take me to this dressing room.
And mind you, I still
haven't seen a script.
I haven't seen anything.
- But you already were willing to do--
- I didn't care.
- Here's the thing.
You collect like little figurines, right?
- Yeah.
- So is that what you were angling for?
- No.
- I want to be a Star Wars figurine?
I just wanted to be in Star Wars.
You don't understand.
When I sat there and saw that
movie for the first time,
I was sitting there saying to myself,
how in the hell do you get
in something like this?
What do you have to do?
Another movie, like Die
Hard, my friend Reginald Vel
is that cop that's
outside eating doughnuts.
I go, how did Reggie get that job?
(audience laughs)
So there are certain things that you watch
that you just want to do.
So when I got there and
I was in my dressing room
or what they said was my dressing room,
they go well somebody will
be up here to help you
put on your costume in a
minute, you're having a fitting.
Cool, I wonder whose dressing room this is
because I see some books and I see, wow,
that looks like a Jedi robe.
I must be in somebody's room.
Then somebody came in and
gave me these three pages.
They go, these are your lines.
And I went, Mace Windu,
who in the hell is that?
And it's just Mace Windu,
Yoda; Mace Windu, Yoda;
Mace Windu, Yoda.
I know I'm not Yoda (audience laughs).
I must be Mace Windu.
Still didn't know who this guy was.
And then they came in
and I put on some boots
and they started putting the stuff on me,
and I'm like, so I'm a Jedi?
And they're like, well, yeah.
I'm like wow, and I'm having
a conversation with Yoda.
So I guess I won't be
edited out of the movie.
So I won't be just running across screen.
And then the guy came
in with the (mumbles),
and he's like pick your lightsaber handle.
I'm like ... (audience applauds)
I can't even tell you what I really did.
I really just went like ...
I was like oh my God, that one,
so that's when I knew I was a Jedi.
- Didn't you think there'd
be a little ceremony
where you'd be ignited as a Jedi?
- I didn't care what was
going to happen at that point.
All I knew was I was a
Jedi, I had my lightsaber,
they told me to go in
this room, I met Frank Oz
and all these guys, because
Yoda was still a puppet then,
so I had to rehearse with these guys
for like hours and hours
while they did ears and eyes
and Yoda stuff, and I was
very cool with all that,
but I made up my mind
then, I was like okay, so,
I just got to be cool and
not give George any grief,
be quiet, stay out of the way,
and see how long I hang around.
Don't let him kill me.
Don't kill me.
And that's what I did.
In the first movie, I sat in
the chair and I was like ...
Everybody was having lightsaber battles.
I wanted to like ...
Let it go, let it go.
(audience laughs)
- I'm cool, I'm fine.
- He'll get to ya.
And I made it through the first one.
So the second one, they
actually sent me a script.
And I'm reading it and I see, oh wow,
there's a huge, huge
battle scene in this arena.
And I'm in it.
But it's like recalled Jedis
from all over the galaxy
to fight in this arena, and I'm like,
how in the hell am I going to find myself
in all this big old fight.
George, do you think I could
have like a purple lightsaber?
(audience laughs)
And he was like, no
Sam, they're either red
or they're green.
But I'm the second baddest
Jedi in the universe,
and I've been around for awhile.
- Purple is kind of in the middle.
- Purple could be like kind of dope.
He said let me think about it.
I didn't bother him.
I go away.
We shoot the movie in Australia.
Then we do re-shoots in London.
And he's all, I got something to show you.
And he pulls it up, and sure
enough, (imitates lightsaber)
purple lightsaber (audience applauds).
But George is still in that space where,
I don't know if I'm going
to let you keep that though,
because somehow it got leaked on the net,
and it's causing this big shit storm.
I'm like, really?
I wonder who leaked that.
(audience laughs)
Eventually, I got to keep it.
It was vanity.
I was trying to find myself
in that big old fight
in the middle of the arena.
- It totally worked.
- It totally works.
I know where I am in that big old fight.
But, you know, George is great like that.
George liked me, I liked
George, and it all worked out.
He finally told me, he said well you know,
you're going to die in episode three.
I'm like, why?
He says well, I've already done
episode four, five, and six,
and you're not in them (audience laughs),
and you're the only significant
character that I can kill
that will make a difference
that moves the story along.
I wasn't too happy about it.
I was like, well can't I
just get my hand cut off
and fall out the window
and not really be dead?
He's like, well, that would
mean you'd have to wait
until episode seven to come
back to be able to be something,
but I'm okay with that.
I had my moment.
It was great.
- The Lucas giveth and
the Lucas take away.
- Yeah, but you know.
- You had a good run.
- It's like the gift that keeps on giving.
They just re-released all that
stuff on Blu-ray and stuff,
so I got another check, I'm good.
- I tell you what.
You're working for (mumbles),
the Superbowl commercial.
Did you get a lot of reaction
on that Superbowl commercial?
- What Superbowl commercial?
- Oh, you know what, my mistake.
- You know what, see, you're as crazy
as the people on Twitter.
I'm not Laurence Fishburne.
(hosts laugh)
- That's my fault, I know that.
That was my fault.
My mistake.
- We don't all look alike.
We may be all black and famous,
but we all don't look alike.
- [Host] You are guilty.
- I am guilty.
- [Host] He thought you were Bob Dylan.
- Right.
- You're an entertainment reporter?
You're an entertainment
reporter for this station,
and you don't know the difference
between me and Laurence Fishburne?
- I know, my mistake,
my mistake, I apologize.
Really, my big mistake.
- There must be a very
short line for your job.
- It probably would not be
hard to get another person
to sit right here.
Let's talk about Robocop.
- Oh hell no.
(hosts laugh)
Really?
- I apologize.
- I'm the other guy.
I'm the other guy, the other one.
What's in your wallet?
There's more than one black
guy doing a commercial.
- No question about that.
- I'm the what's in your wallet black guy.
He's the card black guy.
- There it is.
- Morgan Freeman is the
other credit card black guy
You only hear his voice though,
so you probably won't confuse him
with Laurence Fishburne.
(hosts laugh hysterically)
- I had an interview.
I was doing an interview in
New York almost 20 years ago.
A woman from Texas came up
and interrupted the interview.
I don't mean to bother you,
but can I have your
autograph, Mr. Jackson?
(audience laughs)
And so I gave her, I wrote, you know,
blah blah blah, Sam
Jackson (audience laughs).
So Sam and I have this
running gag about it.
It's like, you know, once upon a time,
people used to confuse Al
Pacino and Dustin Hoffman.
It's not a bad problem to have.
- [Host] Not at all.
- No.
- I mean, obviously I imagine
your work in The Matrix
must have prepared you
for that kind of action.
- Not, not, underline not.
- To confirm, you're not.
- I watched that movie the other night.
I have no idea why people
think we're even remotely--
- You know what it is?
It's because you're both cool.
- Really, is that what it is?
- You're both very cool.
- I thought it was just
a tall and black thing.
- [Host] Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- I appreciate your time.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I made this video because
Dimnitar Georgiev asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What did you learn from this?
What are you going to apply
to your business or your life?
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Mireille.
I hope I pronounced that okay.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is.
Much love guys.
I'll see you soon.
- I didn't get your name.
I got yours, uh, Vincent, right?
But I never got yours.
- My name is Pitt, and your
ass ain't talking your way
out of this shit.
- No, no, no.
I just want you to know--
I just want you to know how sorry we are
that things got so fucked
up with us and Mr. Wallace.
We got into this thing really
with the best of intentions.
Really, I never--
(gun blasts)
- Oh, I'm sorry, did I
break your concentration?
I didn't mean to do that.
Please, continue.
You were saying something
about best intentions.
What's the matter?
Oh, you were finished.
Oh, well allow me to retort.
What does Marsellus Wallace look like?
- What?
- What country are you from?
- What ain't no country I ever heard of.
Do they speak English in What?
- What?
- English motherfucker, do you speak it?
- Yes.
- Then you know what I'm saying.
- Describe what Marsellus
Wallace looks like.
- What?
- Say what again.
Say what again.
I dare you, I double
dare you motherfucker.
Say it one more goddamn time.
- He's black.
- Go on.
- He's bald.
- Does he look like a bitch?
- What? (gun blasts)
(moans in agony)
- Does he look like a bitch?
- No.
- Then why are you trying to
fuck him like a bitch, Brett?
- I didn't.
- Yes you did.
Yes you did Brett.
You tried to fuck him.
And Marsellus Wallace
don't like to be fucked
by anybody except Mrs. Wallace.
You ever read the Bible, Brett?
- Yes.
- Well there's this
passage I got memorized.
It fits this occasion.
Ezechiel 25:17.
The path of the righteous
man is beset on all sides
by the inequities of the
selfish and the tyranny
of evil men.
Blessed is he, who in the
name of charity and good will
separates the week through
the Valley of Darkness.
For he is truly his brother's keeper
and the finder of lost children.
And I will strike down upon
thee with great vengeance
and furious anger those
who attempt to poison
and destroy my brothers, and you will know
my name is the lord when I
lay my vengeance upon thee.
(guns blast)
- Danny, would you relax a little bit?
- I'm relaxed.
I'm very fucking relaxed.
But let me give you some advice.
Never say no to a hostage taker.
It's in the manual.
Now, are you going to tell me no again?
- No, I'm not.
- No, wrong answer.
Eliminate that word from
your vocabulary Farley.
Never use no, don't,
won't, or can't, all right?
It eliminates options.
The only option that leaves is
to shoot someone, understand?
- Yes, yes, I do.
- Yes, see?
Yes is good.
You say no again, I'll
kill somebody, all right?
Now, let's practice.
Can I see a priest?
- Let's not, you know what,
can we just talk about this?
- You wanted to talk.
We are talking.
Now can I see a priest?
- Uh, I'll see what I can do.
- That's good Farley.
Now you're learning.
Now I'd like a sub machine gun
so I can blow everyone away.
- I'll, I'll, I'll look into that.
- Good, you're doing good Farley.
You ever cheat on your wife Farley?
- No.
- [Danny] Watch yourself.
I'll kill someone.
You ever cheat on your wife?
Answer!
- I'll see what I can do.
I'll have to think about that.
I'll look into that.
- You ever um dress up like a school girl
and get your ass spanked Farley?
- Danny, look, okay, all I want to do
is just talk to you.
- I am talking.
Now, did you or did you not ever dress up
like a school girl and
get your ass spanked?
- I'll have to look into that Danny.
- Oh Jesus, Farley, I
got nothing against you
dressing up like a little girl,
but I did not know that about you, Farley.
- Danny, you know, this is
really, really unproductive.
- Unproductive?
You're right, it is.
So, tell me a joke Farley.
You know any jokes?
- No, I--
- No?
You just cost someone their life, Farley.
Game over.
(gun blasts)
- Shot fired.
Shot fired.
Can anyone see?
(crowd chatters excitedly)
- You can't talk me down.
You can't make me change the deadline.
Now get me Sabian.
You got six minutes, 42, 41, 40.
- [Farley] Danny, Danny,
is anybody hurt Danny?
Is anybody hurt?
- We're okay; just don't be
saying no no more motherfucker.
- I just have one more thing Colonel.
Did you have to repeat
your orders to Captain Lee?
- [Colonel] I'm sorry?
- Your ordered Captain Lee
to engage hostile targets,
and he advised you that
there were women and children
in the line of fire, is that correct?
- Well he couldn't see--
- Yes or no Colonel.
Did he follow your first set of orders?
- I don't remember.
- Captain Lee is on record
as saying he hesitated
and mentioned the
sniper's in the building.
Is his testimony accurate?
- I don't remember.
- Let me get this straight.
You evacuate the ambassador.
You go back to the roof.
Two of your Marines are KIA.
A third, Sergeant Crassovich, dies.
You give your captain an
order, which he doesn't follow;
in fact, he questions.
And then you said what?
- (sighs) I don't remember.
- You don't remember what you said next?
- It was combat, not
some training exercise.
- A moment later, your men were shooting.
What did you say to make that happen?
- I don't know.
- You must have said something.
Captain Lee reversed himself.
What did you say?
- I don't know the exact words.
- Let me help you.
- Your honor.
- You said, waste the
motherfuckers, didn't you?
- No, no, no.
- You didn't say it?
- Well, it all happened so fast.
- You're under oath Colonel.
Let me refresh your memory.
This is Exhibit Q, a tape recording made
aboard the USS Wake Island
of all radio communications
received that day,
including your exact words.
Your Honor, with your permission,
I would like to play this tape.
- Well if you got it on tape,
then that's what I said.
They were killing my
Marines so yeah I said it.
Waste the motherfuckers.
- Are these the motherfuckers?
- Objection.
- Overruled.
- Yes.
- These?
- Objection.
- Overruled.
- Yes.
- Are these the motherfuckers
that you ordered
to be wasted?
- Your Honor.
- Major.
- Yes!
- Your Honor.
- The crowd in front of
the embassy had no weapons,
did they, Colonel?
- Objection; we wound no
sniper's weapons either.
- Yes they had weapons.
You think there's a
script for fighting a war
without pissing somebody off?
Follow the rules and nobody gets hurt?
Yes, innocent people probably died.
Innocent people always die,
but I did not exceed my order.
- There are rules, and Marines
are sworn to uphold them.
- I was not going to stand
by and see another Marine die
just to live by those fucking rules.
- (strikes gavel twice) Colonel ...